[Musik]
hey leute heute gibt es ein besonderes
rezept viele kennen das vielleicht gar
nicht aber ich wollte euch heute mein
freund vorstellen nämlich muss kraut
getrocknetes kraut viele kennen das
vielleicht unter dem arabischen begriff
mori und ich persönlich kenne das erst
jetzt zwei jahren durch meine
schwiegermama ich habe generell das
gefühl in der türkei ist mir jetzt nicht
so weit verbreitet
vielleicht könnt ihr mir in die
kommentare schreiben woher er kommt und
ob ihr das schon kennt aus eurer
national küche und ich weiß auch gar
nicht ob es die magnetisch ist oder oder
oder
also ich glaube es ist libanesisch aber
wie immer bei der zitter lässt sich die
streifen nieder hat irgendwie so seine
art und weise das zuzubereiten ich zeige
euch heute meine art und weise und dass
sie es gibt halt eben getrocknet oder
frisch frisch findet man sehr selten
ich habe hier die getrocknete variante
die gibt es übrigens auch in unserem
shop deswegen fand ich das so toll dass
ich euch sagen kann roasters gibt und
dass ich euch das rezept hier zeigen
kann und ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal
noch die restlichen zutaten
wir benötigen wohl auch hier dass es
getrocknetes kraut außerdem
hähnchenschenkel hier habe ich eine
zwiebel und koriander ganz viel
knoblauch außerdem zitronensaft hier
habe ich noch sieben gewürze rabatte hat
dazu sage ich euch gleich was außerdem
mit salz und pfeffer und butter und ich
bin froh dass ich euch mal jetzt zum
richtigen zeitpunkt vorstellen darf denn
ihr wisst ja gar nicht wie viele
nährstoffe enthält das ist ja schon fast
ein super fort so ein kleines
unentdecktes wie ich finde
denn viele kennen das ja wirklich noch
gar nicht und das erste was wir jetzt
machen müssen ich habe das jetzt in zwei
schlüsseln gegeben weil das wirklich
viel inhalt ist aber dass reduziert sie
später als das erste was wir machen
müssen einmal lauwarmes wasser darüber
geben und dann 15 minuten stehen lassen
so und in 15 minuten machen wir dann
weiter was ich euch aber noch ganz
dringend sagen muss es gibt so ein und
so ein mode also es gibt natürlich
verschiedene firmen und manchmal ist es
so dass da noch der stängel dran ist
also der stil und der müsste dann
unbedingt vor dem einreichen abmachen
das dauert dann auch etwas zeit bei mir
ist es so also bei diesem produkt sind
jetzt nicht dran da sind die mühsam per
hand schon im vorfeld abgemacht die
arbeit wohl schon erledigt und deshalb
musste ich das jetzt eben nicht machen
so die 15 minuten sind rum und sieht man
auch schon das wasser hat sich verfärbt
und das was wir jetzt machen müssen ganz
ganz wichtig einmal komplett ausspülen
und zwar beide schüsseln und besten mit
lauwarmem wasser
[Musik]
so ganz wichtig ist dass sie das jetzt
aus bringt und zurück in die schüsse
gibt wenn wir machen was deswegen damit
er nichts schleimiges hier bleibt der
schleimige konsistenz wer hier sehr sehr
unbeliebt und schmeckt auch leider
überhaupt nicht gut
[Musik]
was genau also ist er hält mich selber
schon an deine mama weil das gibt es da
ganz ganz oft und ich freue mich sogar
mal wenn es das gibt und schaut mal so
wenig ist jetzt noch übrig das ist jetzt
alles was wir haben in einer schüssel es
brauche ich die zweite gar nicht mehr
und wichtig ist dass wir den vorgang
jetzt wiederholen also wieder lauwarm
ist was da drauf 15 minuten warten und
noch mal richtig schön aus bringen
das machen wir deshalb damit der ganze
schleier aus ist wenn ich gerade schon
erwähnt habe nur ihr ohne schleim ist da
freu mich über eure gäste
wenn jemand moderierten das freilich ist
dann möchte man es gar nicht mehr essen
[Musik]
nebenbei kurz gepostet und mich bedankt
für über 100.000 abonnenten auf
instagram und wer weiß wenn das video
online geht schon vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr
und genau das dafür nämlich auch nicht
vergessen ohne euch wären wir jetzt auch
nicht da wo wir sind und ich könnte euch
dieses mal auch ihr rezept zeigen
deshalb machen jetzt auch direkt weiter
ich mache jetzt wieder den nächsten
vorgang wie der ausspülen aus regen und
bis kein stein mehr da ist
[Musik]
unser muss kraut ist jetzt fertig
vorbereitet es gebe ich jetzt nur noch
ganz kurz an die seite wie gesagt
wiederholt den vorgang einfach beliebig
oft bis wirklich kein stein mehr da ist
so ganz ganz ganz könnte die nicht
wegkriegen wenn ihnen ausdruck da merkt
jeder ist irgend eine ganz leichte
schleimige konsistenz aber im kochen
verschwindet das dann komplett und jetzt
kümmere ich mich noch ganz kurz um den
koriander bevor ich an den herd drüber
gehe
der wird jetzt ganz einfach sehr fein
gehackt
[Musik]
somit wäre die schnitzel arbeit auch
erledigt das benutzt du mir gleich denn
ich zeige euch jetzt zuallererst wie wir
das hähnchen würzen und wie wir das gern
kochen denn ich möchte das jetzt schon
mal vorbereiten
das braucht nämlich gleich 45 minuten
bis eine stunde und ich habe jetzt hier
einen großen topf 4 habe ich wasser rein
gegeben reichlich wasser und lass das
aufkochen und ich werde jetzt
zuallererst meine sieben gewürze
eingeben labbadia hat das ist so lecker
und passt perfekt zum hähnchen das
bekommt ihr eigentlich auch dort wo es
orientalisch lebensmittel gibt aber
natürlich auch bei mir im shop das
wollte ich auch in der schnell nochmal
erwähnen
also falls ihr euch vor ihr kauft das am
besten mit dabei dann hat das schon euer
starterkits sage ich mal
und das gebe ich jetzt da rein und das
salz und pfeffer kommt dazu
und für den letzten geschmack kommt noch
eine zwiebel rein da habe ich ganz
einfach die haut entfernt so als ganzes
einmal rein geben das ist jetzt nicht
plumpsen
sonst habe ich dann hier alles voll so
und natürlich das fleisch mit rein geben
und dann das ganze aufkochen lassen und
bis klar ist dauert sonst je nachdem wie
groß ihr fleisch ist 45 bis 60 minuten
[Musik]
so wird das fleisch vor sich hin kocht
mache ich weiter mit dem anderen topf
bzw mit der fahne dann nämlich ist eine
beschichtete aber können natürlich auch
einen ausreichend großen topf verwenden
und jetzt haben wir ganz ganz viel
knoblauch und wir brauchen auch wirklich
so viel und das passt einfach perfekt
ist fasst es schmeckt so lecker und
entweder hat die ihn jetzt fallen oder
ihr reibt ihn und das mache ich jetzt so
aber vorher gebe ich noch ein stück
butter in einer pfanne und las dass auch
mittlerer hitze ein wenig schmelzen
wichtig ist nicht die hohe hitze nehmen
wenn butter kann ganz schnell anbrennen
[Musik]
den knoblauch habe ich jetzt eine minute
lang auf mittlerer stufe angedünstet und
jetzt kommt der koriander mit dazu so
einfach eine minute lang mit diensten
und dann nimmt er am besten immer
messerrücken damit ihr auch eure messer
nicht kaputt macht so und der nächste
schritt ist einfach unser moskau nach
und nach mit dazu zu geben
so und wenn ihr dann merkt okay es fehlt
jetzt noch ein bisschen was an butter
dann gibt mir immer an nach und nach
also wirklich machen nach einer mutter
mit dazu dann könnte man abschätzen wie
viel ihr letztendlich benötigt
so ist habe ich das komplette
eingegebenen die fahne und an der stelle
also ich bin jetzt auf stufe acht von
neun an der stelle einfach zehn minuten
dann richtig schön in empfang im hotel
schwenken anbraten und dann zeige ich
euch den nächsten schritt gehen so das
ganze jetzt noch salzen und danach kommt
unser hühner so also die hühnerbrühe da
rein
ich habe jetzt extra nen ganz großen
topf genommen oder ganz viel wasser
daran getan damit ich mir jetzt was weg
schöpfen kann und auch unsere module
geben kann
[Musik]
und zwar gibt jetzt so viel wasser
darüber bis es gerade so bedeckt ist das
schon ob das so in ordnung ist ja das
reicht so und jetzt muss noch ein
bisschen geduld haben eine stunde lang
ist das ganze jetzt vor sich hin köcheln
auf mittlerer stufe also geht ein
bisschen niedriger lieber von der stufe
und das ganze mit geschlossenem deckel
ansonsten würde euch das ganze jahr
verdampfen es sollte möglichst flüssig
denn das den deckel ganz einfach weg die
hähnchenschenkel die nehme ich jetzt
raus aus dem hühner so denn die sind gar
die für einmal hier zum abtropfen und
zum erkalten also erkalten in
anführungszeichen ich gebe es jetzt
erstmal hier die schüsse denn die sind
noch sehr heiß und wir müssen sehr mit
den händen auseinander rutschen deshalb
lasse ich sie aus dampfen und macht das
dann
und später wenn wir das zum wohle geben
also zum topf geben dann wird auch
wieder warm und dann könnte alles schön
heiß genießen
so und jetzt darf ich das sehe ich mit
meinen händen könnte jetzt natürlich
auch ganz fein mit zwei gabeln machen
aber mit den händen funktioniert einfach
viel viel besser
also ich würde gerne nutzen du gerade
dafür dass hände nehmen wir das gewusst
und ist fällt er aber benutzt noch immer
ein paar hände frei ist
und jetzt wird das fleisch einfach nur
noch rein gegeben und gut untergerührt
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt die zitrone zum einen
das runde ding geschmack richtig ab und
ihr könnt auch hier immer ein bisschen
über die arbeitsplatte rollen damit auch
richtig viel saft raus kommt und jetzt
ganz einfach dazu geben und dann
herrschte da muss ich noch mal sagen es
kommt es ganz darauf an wie ihr das am
liebsten mit lieber so also ihr seht ihr
hier ist jetzt kein lob übrig oder es
ist feucht aber nicht flüssig oder
möchte ist überflüssig wie so eine
richtige soße dann könnt ihr noch ein
bisschen hühner süd nehmen und desto zu
geben und jetzt gebe ich noch den
kompletten hühner sot einmal zur fahne
so und es ist vollkommen in ordnung dass
es jetzt sehr flüssig ist denn genau so
war es klar
so meine lieben die arbeit hinten am
spülbecken hat sich definitiv ausgezahlt
das modul ist perfekt dass der oder die
minuten ich kenne diesen artikel gar
nicht ich weiß es nicht aber auf jeden
fall sehr sehr lecker und nicht
schleimig dass das aller aller
wichtigste
sie lädt dazu am besten bereich den habe
ich hier schon gekocht und auf jeden
fall noch zitronenscheiben gerne auch
joghurt das machen wir bei der mama
immer ne super lecker joghurt dazu und
euch jetzt ganz ganz viel spaß beim
nachkochen ich bin gespannt auf euer
feedback in den kommentaren wenn es dann
probiert habt und genau willst du noch
was sagen ach quatsch das ist nicht viel
aber es könnte auch einfach noch mehr
reis auf den teller
ja so und wie es jetzt und wünschen euch
auch einen guten appetit wenn ich
ausprobiert und freuen uns wenn ihr beim
nächsten mal wieder einschaltet zu einem
neuen ramadan videos eure ki
[Musik]